we're taking numbers taking phone calls
at six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty let's try going to the four
one five area code who's calling today
from four one five I did it hey who's
this Oh Ian hey Ian what's going on um I
love your show uh I guess I'm looking
progressive you're like a progressive
are you a progressive sure okay uh I
guess one of my biggest critique of
Bernie Sanders is that I don't like the
$15 minimum wage okay why not good for
some steak that's too much okay I don't
totally disagree in terms of the
economic impact that would have although
I still believe everybody should make
that I agree with you that there are
states where the wage is 725 we're more
than doubling it will have a a impact so
I'm not totally against what you're
saying so far so like how do you do with
that problem right
well so the way I'm dealing with it
increasingly is by just making the
conversation about the fact that a $15
minimum wage it's still only a band-aid
and it doesn't really get to a lot of
the underlying and growing issues so $15
minimum wage is not going to deal in any
substantive way with the system that we
have which allows for just like insane
inequality on the backs of working
people for the benefit of rich and
corporations $15 minimum wage it'll lift
a couple million people out of poverty
we saw a report that it'll raise the
wages of about 27 million people it will
cause some job losses but it's not going
to fix the fact that corporations and
the rich are able to continue growing
their wealth while everybody else's wage
is mostly stagnate it's not going to
deal with technological automation it is
not going to deal with the reality that
cost of living in some parts of the
country has cartoonishly exploded while
in other is it's still relatively modest
so I I'm trying to deal more with that
bigger picture than the minutia of the
15 minimum with a $15 minimum wages
effect at this
state-level because I agree with you the
effect is going to be different in
different states and it's it's going to
vary what the what the wage should be in
different parts of the country varies
not only between states but even often
within states like New York City versus
rural upstate New York so basically it
sounds like you and I agree oh oh great
yeah I'm excited
all right very good appreciate the call
important issue and one that we will
keep talking about we're going to take a
quick break but if you're holding please
don't hang up because we do have time
for some more calls right after this
break stay with me